got a new pickup artist for you
just francis how i got laid during a
protest
all right well you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] with a name like francis i mean
i would hope you go by frank
wait till you see this chat oh my god i
i hope you're getting skills are better
than your video editing skills
this is him
somebody used to have piercings in his
lips oh god yeah you can tell
yep those don't go away
he films himself making out with chicks
in today's video i'm going to show you
how to pick up women
during a protest oh my god
what is he a full-grown person because i
can't tell
he might be from washington heights i
don't know
pandemic stay tuned for more
everything from his underbite to his
[ __ ]
oh yeah i hate this guy francis dating
how are you holding up it's
intense all of it okay so another
completely staged completely pre-planned
get together
it's not as bad as it was it's not at
all this is
yeah it's like really sticky
correct you've been here a couple days
every day okay yeah wednesday is it
tuesday or wednesday tuesday was bad
yeah i was in hollywood on tuesday when
it was like 95
and we were marching right that's yeah
this is his pickup tactic is what talk
about the weather
and then keep yammering over him he's
doing that thing that uh
when people do it to me i want to
[ __ ] smash him in the face
she's talking and he's what's happening
three times you don't like when people
but it was hot yes but no you do you you
start saying like it was hot
yeah you know it was hot yesterday was
it was 95 degree
got it yeah it was really sticky it's
very hot
that's what he's doing it's so annoying
very well yeah
so i'm going to skip around the whole
military video that's another heavy
presence that they have over there
and then yeah at the persian square
yeah i mean it's it's like so you're not
even really protesting you're trying to
get laid
is that what this is yeah he's pulling
the dennis and mac at the abortion rally
good you got like a whole six-pack
minion
like i keep preparing no i like
i it's gonna sound corny and i won't say
what i'm gonna what i'm gonna say but
like i probably it's been a very long
time that i met someone that's like
really
prepared for like that that just
there shows a lot about your personality
that you're kind of calm down
relax buddy right he's coming [ __ ]
relax
he's coming off the way i have i would
come off
like in a job interview when i've been
looking for work for like
three months you know where you get that
like oh yeah no that's great
like you're still getting way too eager
get out of here
they were amazing yeah i was walking
around
is he riding his bicycle
i'm sorry where's your [ __ ] getting
bicycle
check this out check this out though
so he offers one of these chicks a ride
films it films it
in car audio is a bit difficult to hear
so we have to skip through this section
yeah it's difficult to hear because you
were filming in secret yeah which is
creepy
yeah watch
this is a different chick that he gave a
ride to
nice filthy carpet in your car too
what the hell is this he's doing he's
buckling her
is she a toddler how old is that vehicle
you could tell by the seat belts and by
the front that that's an
old [ __ ] car is that an el camino
maybe it's the the seats are filthy yeah
floor was filthy
he put carpeting over the dash because
the dash is probably
so shot is this woman homeless
she doesn't appear to maybe not homeless
but
not doing well
what the [ __ ]
does that make anyone else
really uncomfortable or am i the only
one who's very uncomfortable by
okay can i can i
can i can i break this down please do
now i'm gonna operate under the
assumption this is real i'm not
i don't believe any of the things these
guys do in real life but let's pretend
let's pretend let's pretend this is a
real
organic situation you offered somebody a
ride
you buckled her into the seat belt which
is
very weird it's not like holding a door
or something like buckling them in is
very weird
then once they were buckled in and kind
of stuck
you grabbed her face and forced yourself
onto her
right am i am i reading this right you
buckled her in so now it's like i'm
stuck
now i'm trapped and then once you're
trapped ah
that's everything about this just gave
me
the [ __ ] creeps she can't say no
that's what i mean because of the
implication
but it's this is
either she maybe she's a hooker or
homeless these pickup artists guys man
you guys are the only ones you're the
only ones who manage
to make me simp for women the only time
i ever sound like a simp is when we
watch these guys videos where i'm like
okay this is basically like assault
this seems aggressive this seems
very aggressive
arnold nicotina says she can't say no
because she doesn't speak english i hope
you're kidding
i hope that was a joke
i can't even watch this no no we're
watching this
you don't want to know how to pick up
chicks
step one make sure they're homeless not
like this
step two give them money
also notice the chick that's in the car
is none of the women that they showed
previously that he was hitting on in the
videos
no this just seems to be a random
straggler
this is making me very angry i'm not
kidding like this is making me
very angry is this a different chick now
or whatever
that's a different chick right got her
mcdonald's at least
i think it's a different trick anyway
and she's not asking about the camera
that you keep filming with that you just
moved to the top of a car
so what you just watched in this video
here is basically
sexual assault i
dis dude even for the pickup artist
we've covered
this is probably one of the worst cases
i hate this man
i hate this man
so what you just watched in this video
here is basically a girl that i met on
the street
and persisted and pursued
as further as i can without
ever ejecting you have to ask yourself
when was the last time that i actually
ejected
sooner than she wanted me to
i what okay so
he has an underbite he has a lisp he's
i he drives a [ __ ] car i i hate
everything about this creep
this guy's a [ __ ] ghoul even for a
pickup artist he's a ghoul
it was an el camino by the way i was
right
without ever ejecting you have to ask
yourself
when was the last time that i actually
ejected
wait do you mean like when was the last
time i
ejected or when was the last time i made
myself eject because i mean i
i self-eject all the time yeah like
ejecting into the toilet
into like a [ __ ] tissue tube sock
whatever yeah
sooner than she wanted me to am i
staying in set and thinking she doesn't
want me in it but you're still in set
so you eject what's in set i'm sorry
does anyone understand
again anyone used to watch old tv videos
what does that mean he's all
no this probably is his own stuff like
again this is what these guys all do
it's it's we could easily do this if we
wanted to it's very easy to just
somebody yeah well not that i mean like
creating these programs right
there's certain things you got to do you
have to have a step process
you have to have um and then you have to
have your own it's the same way with
cults
you have to have your own inside lingo
because that's part of what the people
are paying
for people are paying to feel like
they're in on some [ __ ] other people
don't know about
so there's all these code phrases and
stuff and it's all
it's all like community lingo
that he's using am i staying in set
and thinking she doesn't want me in it
but you're still in set so you eject
or am i going to pursue until she
literally says f off
okay ask yourself this question okay
i hope you enjoyed that's it i'll see
you on the next one
i didn't get any of the pickup line stop
it
so just so he looks like a mexican
crispy remember crispy the rapper that
we covered
yes he does you know
so what i learned from this was
and maybe i'm wrong royce let me know if
i misread any of this
what i learned from this is that it's
best for me to
drive around looking for homeless women
whose
legal status in this country is also
questionable
um convince them to get into my car
force the seat belt onto them strap them
in like they're a toddler in a car seat
and then force my mouth onto her mouth
oh but buyer mcdonald's too can you re
can
you read the title of this video for
everyone mike jesus christ
can you read the title of it for
everyone they might not be able to see
it because the way everything is put up
you're going to make me do this yes
please uh this this
this guy's just a sex this guy's just
like a
right like is what he is he's not even a
pickup artist this guy's
just a [ __ ] his the title is
how to finger a girl in a nightclub
parenthesis clickbait non-click bait
at some point don't you get a little too
old for these tactics
i mean at some point though you get a
little too old for this lifestyle period
how come some faces are blurred out and
some aren't
i will tell you why i at first i was
thinking
uh releases and stuff no because the
four people are probably his friends
and they probably engage in a lot of
this borderline illegal behavior
and he probably doesn't want his friends
to get found out right right you're
right yeah i think you're right
she seems pretty [ __ ] hammer dude
yeah she's [ __ ] up dude yeah
and look i'm not even one of those like
you know people get drunk and they
[ __ ] and i think a lot of the times
people
women try to be like oh i was but when
like they're leaning on you because they
can't stand
there are predatory dudes like not every
woman that
has regret after having sex is has been
and some of them are full of [ __ ] but
also they do have valid points
women do have valid points about going
out and not feeling safe and [ __ ]
because you have
sharks like this swimming around all the
time like oh
i'll take it i'll take her home i'll
give her a ride
okay this woman barely knows where she
is
how does that feel
i like how he's protecting her identity
with just one little black bar over her
eyes
yeah also i like the uh the videos how
to finger in a girl how to finger a girl
in a nightclub step one
find a girl who's so drunk she doesn't
even know where she is
step two insert your fingers into her
vagina i think this is him doing it and
that's how you do it
he's doing it
but we are not allowed on youtube
because we make jokes
we're the problem
where the issue susan
you know if i if i got like
completely like wastey face
and then like the next day somebody
showed me a video like this
of me
i would be absolutely mortified
like i would be i can't even describe to
you how
shitty i would feel if somebody showed
me a video like this of me
i'd be like jesus christ was that me
last night like
holy [ __ ] that would be like a wake-up
call
i certainly wouldn't be posting it on
youtube myself
as if it's some kind of a victory you
know
jesus dude
i'm really pissed off right now
yeah he's in there i'm i'm actually like
pissed
off he's in there
he is in there that's the end of the
video but yeah we we can't get monetized
for
whatever reason
well it's this is oh no that's look why
is it six hours long
what is this
pu affirmations for men deep inner game
attraction seduction and relaxation
meditation
oh so it's one of those videos that you
listen to when you go to bed
and it'll hypnotize you into getting
[ __ ]
you know what be funny though i want to
make a video like this where it's like
your
your pickup artist sensual seduction
like
uh um whatever hypnotizing video but
it'll just be like that chinese
massage parlor music and in the
background all you'll hear
is the clips from uh world peace of uh
sam hyde in the mc trex video sketch
it's just sam hyde whispering the whole
time
i'm that big dick gorilla daddy i make
[ __ ] wet drama alert
he spelled alert wrong all right i want
you to say
i'm that gorilla dick i make [ __ ] wet
i'm not i'm not saying the n word
okay say i'm that big dick gorilla daddy
i make [ __ ] wet drama alert
spelled alert wrong girl call security
on my student
it's hilarious because you're like
you're like
kind
[Applause]
we started baby stepping we start doing
the strip hotels
and um we didn't go quite the far away
now what you're gonna see in these
upcoming
daytime clips opposed to that one
previous that was the night prior going
into the venue
on a friday night this is saturday
morning we're walking in there stuff
like that
and um it's uh the main issue you're
gonna be seeing in the next several
clips is basically
moving in too fast guys watch how just
he's throwing too much
he's going too many steps in you mean
like i don't know fingering a blackout
drunk girl
two seconds after you meet him or
strapping a woman into a car and then
grabbing her face and jamming your
tongue into her mouth like
like wait he what you're telling me is
that he moved
faster than that
what what is i will be expanding on that
it's random but i saw you
this dude gives off massive vibes no
thank you
about what no thank you for what are you
having a bad day
she said no thank you that should be and
then that's it
look i'm not saying don't try try i
don't get it i get it man i do
but at that point you stop right
what do you speak italian i'll say this
oh if if a girl is like whatever not
whatever it's
i will say i will defend it
if you're let's say you're both
sitting down at a bar and you're
like it doesn't you're not and when i
say this i don't mean like you got up
walked over to where they're sitting
or you know what i mean like where
you're in their space but if you're both
sitting in a bar
and some chicks like i'm not interested
i have a boyfriend
you can still be like sitting at the bar
watching tv talking to other people
you could still like bust their chops a
little bit and bring them into the
conversation and try to maybe turn it
around
but when you're on foot this is just
you're chasing them yeah you're
literally chasing them at that point
so you must speak un poquito de espanol
i think you're lying to me you speak
very good english
dude dude take no for an answer man
you're doing it right okay number one
thing as well too he goes in boom the
girl gets creeped out
no no thank you obviously he came too
aggressive like we've been talking about
well be aware of your surroundings you
know there might be like people that are
trying to sell you
uh tours they might be trying to sell
you hookers uh anywhere wherever you at
don't come out like a solicitor but if
you get stuck in that moment where she
was like no thank you am i like
immediately your go-to my go-to since
they um
not since day one but at some point i
was like oh [ __ ] i'm creeping around but
i put my hands up and i'm just like hey
hey
do you think that makes it better wait
i'm sober i'm not
crazy i'm not crazy i'm not gonna hurt
you
i'm not gonna hurt you why stop running
does he think that's good that's a good
way to handle it
oh my god i'm not gonna bash your brains
in with a piece of concrete
i'm gonna kill you come here i love you
dude this guy
honestly i i i think i'd be able to
laugh at him a little bit more
if he didn't give off such
insane vibes to me
you know like this i would laugh more if
there wasn't such a [ __ ]
darkness to this guy also are you
also are you implying that when you
drink you're violent
because you should all people shouldn't
have to be worried about you hurting
them when you're drunk
either yeah because i would never say
that i would first of all i would never
put my hands up and tell a woman i'm
sober
don't worry i'm totally straight and
arrow
yeah he must be that is a weird thing
like you said if he says that then he
might be a problem drinker because who
says that
like like most of the women that i've
had in my life have actually told me
like
could you please get drunk like you're
not since they won but
at some point i was like oh [ __ ] i'm
creeping around but i put my hands up
and i'm just like hey
hey whoa whoa i'm sober
i'm i'm not violent just trying to
trying to get to know you
uh it's okay whatever comes to mind but
all i need is like whoa hey
i'm not that guy just relax but you are
that guy
yeah you're being that guy by not just
saying all right and leaving
okay and by the way this isn't even like
a simping for women things no
it's i'm the kind of guy if you come up
to me and i'll tell you i'm not
interested and like
not even a woman i mean it could be a
solicitor it could be somebody who wants
me to sign a [ __ ] petition
whatever we all kind of agree on the
social contracts of life and one of
those contracts is if somebody tells you
you no longer have my consent to
continue to bother me
that's the end it's over whether it's a
business thing
whether it's [ __ ] whatever it is when a
person tells you to leave them alone
they're not
interested it's not see these guys
think that like getting laid or is like
selling a car you just haven't sold her
good enough yet
some people just aren't interested hey
i'm sober
such a weird thing to say oh briefly
momentarily
whatever the case but honestly that
could find a girl and then boom
the next thing too is boom he brings up
the accent she's italian
how are you gonna get confused now i
understand if you're new watching this
video but do your homework
uh just look at a map honestly um look
at a map
and i always suggest looking at
different places um you know
he's she said i'm italian and right away
do you speak spanish like
i'm telling people don't speak spanish
like that's
a whole different thing you're right
that's how he that's when i realized too
that he blew it
yeah i wasn't saying it was not chasing
her down on foot
yeah it was the uh it was the confusing
two
very comparable latin based languages
was the part that was very weird
not the chasing a woman sweaty through a
ball
there's like two strikes that he's on
right now and he'll make a few more uh
until that was pretty much you know
that now you're doing it right now
well you're doing it you're doing it so
i'll leave you in vegas
how is this different than when they
criticize like you know black dudes for
hollering at a girl or mexican dudes or
whatever like
this this is annoying like this is an
annoy
and again like you said i ain't [ __ ]
sipping for women but if anybody were to
bother me this much for anything i'd
tell them
bro leave me the [ __ ] alone and as a guy
we do have the luxury
that many women don't where you can be
like look man i try to be nice but like
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up if you keep this
[ __ ] up like i'm gonna break this
[ __ ] bottle right in your face
if you don't leave me the [ __ ] alone and
like women can't really assert
themselves that way
what
oh my god it's so i i don't know how
any of these guys ever get laid like
this it's obnoxious
also what is this call i'm sorry i don't
mean to to to
make this about something else but what
is this all these people dressed in
white what is this cult doing over here
you see that and then over here what's
that about
man is he hitting on a girl at a having
skate meeting
they're all watching them too which is
weird what's happening
okay
oh my god i'm so annoyed i would be like
leave me alone what language do i need
to tell you to [ __ ] off in
italian italian
wow you look so sexy when you're serious
this is uncomfortable
i am i mean it's the it's just
desperately throwing
this is like when i used to work in
sales they were good there was like me
my buddy joel my buddy ron we're very
good at sales
and a lot of other people that worked
there we would see them they would read
these books on sales or they would
like go to these training meetings and
then they would do
the things they were taught but like in
this rigid system
and it was like you know they go like
well you know uh ask your ask your
client
open-ended questions things that don't
have a definite yes or no
and the more questions you ask you're
building a rapport with that client
and you'd have guys that would just
bombard people with questions
while they were looking at a mattress
like you married what do you do for a
living
yeah you like that what do you do for
fun what do you do and it's like to the
point where they're like i gotta do the
questions i gotta ask the questions
i gotta ask the questions like when you
think of things that rigidly
you're gonna make people uncomfortable
and weirded out
the reason me ron and joel did well in
sales is because we
did all the [ __ ] you're taught not to do
but it made us like like i would walk up
to somebody and be like
he's anybody helping you out yeah we're
actually working with aaron right now
i'd be like oh yeah that's fine
i mean aaron's literally though so i
mean let me know if you need it and they
would laugh and they'd be like no you
seem all right i'd be like no he's
literally
so anyway what's up but like that [ __ ]
works more than where'd you come from
where'd you get here what are you
looking for what kind of mattress do you
like what about and it's like dude shut
up
shut up you know what i do with those
people is i'm just like
i've i've done it to them i'd be like do
me a favor can you cut the shale stick i
know what you're doing i've been through
the same training stop
and normally they they get off guard and
they'll stop eventually he's like you
gotta stop ben
you gotta [ __ ] stop like you go look
man
if you ask me one more qualifying
question i'm gonna bury my fist in your
[ __ ] bread basket
and they're like i'll let you know if i
have a question
the belcher in the chat says you're sexy
when you're terrified
you're sexy when you're terrified
that's an intense look i can go yeah
okay are you upset wait wait wait wait
i'm not that type of guy i just came
over it was a pause that was a settle
you rewinded back 15 20 seconds when did
she stop
that indicator right there and it went
kind of silent for a moment well
just kind of checking him out see who
he's up to there's about a three
foot proximity between both of them like
keep going keep going
and bring yourself up but it's the
things you say and how aggressive do you
come she's small petite
italian girl she's probably just
traveling by herself maybe maybe so what
i'm going to do is i'm just going to
basically make the correction like i
suggested him
good proximity say distance there's
cameras watching come
under the radar everything is a [ __ ]
business transaction within
all the contracts everything everything
they don't know how to be
people that's why i hate these people
because it's it's
every they're they're they're teaching
these things which is
and literally like these pickup artist
classes are basically
just breeding grounds and training
schools
for future serial killers because once
you start to reduce
all of your um your human interactions
to these systems and once once
everything's a transaction and once
everything's a system
that's starts the process of
dehumanizing women in your mind
and it's really not that much of a leap
to go from that to
you know being and murdering truck stop
hookers it's not a really huge leap at
that point and it just doesn't
dehumanize women it dehumanizes you
you know these people are all [ __ ] on
the spectrum anyway they're barely human
as it is